man was at my wedding because Suzy knew
him before I knew him so he was sitting
there in an electric blue tuxedo when I
was Susan
he was at my baby naming he spoke at my
daughter tailors baby naming all she saw
I love this man I worked with this man I
don't know how many years now but and I
always like to think that I'm his most
favorite person in the room but when the
Vince Lombardi Trophy is sitting between
the two of us it's so funny you start
with this because I'm gonna tell you
something man yes when I was playing I
made a pact that I would never go to a
Super Bowl until I play in the Super
Bowl okay okay you guys showing it and I
love how you and Dan you know start off
each other's show beginning of the week
you know and then then I look on the
board as I'm signing the boards I seed
your head Rodney Harrison yes it was
great he put Rodney Harrison oh three oh
four Super Bowl champs course I saw it
right after Rodney I put my glove in
twenty seven twenty eight thirty champ
you know so every guest that comes here
they're going to get Super Bowl
questions that's why I always said I
would never go to a Super Bowl until
after Super Bowl so what was it like
taking this trophy up for the first time
it was the greatest thing was dancing oh
my god man first of all you got to go
back and think about like we were one in
15 we're three and 13 1 and 15 when
you're 3 and 13 and 1 and 15 Cleveland
Browns I know you don't think there's
any chance that you were ever lay ahold
of something like this so to go from
those days to coming in 92 and winning
that Super Bowl and actually somebody
handing you that trophy
the most incredible thing most
incredible feeling in the world and I
remember I promised her I thought about
it there I said I got one now every year
they will replay cuz that's what they do
every year during Super Bowl time to
replay the Super Bowl
I'm in that mix that's all I wanted to
do was get in that mix so do you think
that's what keeps Brady coming back is
that that he wants to keep on pushing
the limits of what quarterbacks can do
in this yeah you know what keeps Brady
coming back it's that little kid
the little Tom Brady then everybody
picked on that everybody said or never
do it that everybody obviously put some
some reptilian bunk genes in his brain
and made him such a fighter he is such a
great fight I love it he's he's he just
wants to be the greatest ever and I mean
knock it out of the park and kill all
discussions about who's the greatest
ever we moved it now it used to be as
he's greatest quarterback ever yeah yeah
everybody yes that now we moved into is
he the greatest football player ever
and everybody's yes and that soon he's
going to be rival and Jordan for the
greatest athlete period ever and and
he's mountain towards Jordan right
Michael Michael Jordan Michael Jordan
yeah I mean we've already mentioned
LeBron a Federer reference Roger Federer
just went its 20th Grand Slam over the
weekend and Brady is definitely he's
already in that great but what separates
this makes you know in each of those
little basketball you have five guys on
or on for one time LeBron basically
moves the balance of power by himself
whenever he goes to another that city's
that teams going to the Eastern
Conference final that's just what LeBron
is he's one guy that could do it
Brady has to move around so many more
guys it's just incredible that's why
what he's doing man is just phenomenal
and and I say desert we are all blessed
we're all blessed and when God takes us
from time to eternity we should go up
and shake his hand and say thank you for
allowing me to live in the Belichick
Brady yes see that greatness on a
football field because that's what it is
well unless you're trying to get to the
AFC Championship yourself I mean there's
a there's a lot of there's a lot of to
use your analogies they're a hell of a
lot of Ewings and Karl Malone's and you
know and there's some people that are
hoping to be the Hakeem Olajuwon is once
Brady actually
might step away at some point you know
right on the side right here you know
that's the card is the Bradys there's
left left beside him just left back
there
now using credit you made an interesting
comment michael irvin here on the Rich
Eisen show on the on our game day
morning a couple weeks ago I want to
delve into here because you you nailed
it right on the head when we were
talking about Brady and Belichick maybe
having a tug of war yeah and you're like
this needs to be nipped in the bud
because you once saw a dynasty yeah I
have a tug of war that you thought never
never would lead to a breakup never you
know and when I heard it as they were
talking back in the day but about Jerry
and Jimmy are we good there's no way
we're coming off back-to-back Super
Bowls like they may very well be coming
off back-to-back Super Bowls that's in
no way nobody takes a perfectly running
car and take it to the shop we don't
need to shop right now we're learning
perfectly and that's exactly what
happened and and that worries me because
you start talking about these are two
highly successful you know highly
motivated very directed and and and very
I believe I know the way to get it done
type guys and and that's always a
possibility when you have those type men
working together but they're two
incredible people
I certainly hope nothing happens and
they stay together because like I said
we're blessed to be in this time if they
are well the difference is is that these
two guys are under contract to a to an
owner that wants to keep them together
as opposed to an owner wanting to prove
that I can do it myself did you ever
step in when you heard the Jimmy and
Jerry were not doing well or you just
your station wasn't that I really I was
like what are you joking you know how
hard it is doing superposing and you
have a formula it's working and and who
would touch that formula so I really
never thought that there was a need to
because I didn't think anything would
happen and then when it happens like
my god like you know I should have done
this maybe I should have talked to him I
should have tried this I should it's
right that you know so so I hope and
that's a good thing you mentioned if I'm
Robert Crowley I love both of you and
I'll tell you Jerry Jones I'm telling
you it's supposed to one thing I'll
never forget Jerry Jones telling me that
when I was negotiating with him and I
was saying you know I'll go to
Cincinnati and it was just I'm just
talking trying to get my monies up I
said I'll go to Cincinnati you get car
pickings over here and let's see what
happened and Jerry said to me the agira
said Michael you know when I see you I
see Michael Irvin and the Dallas Cowboys
he says kind of see like Magic Johnson
in the Lakers he said what is Magic
without the lake us and what other
Lakers worked out a magic he said you
guys they belong together just like you
and the Cowboys he said Michael the best
way I could tell you if a bomb hit
Valley Ranch today that's where we
practice and everything when the smoke
clears better maybe we don't still be
here so we might as well work this deal
out right now as he was telling me know
about my money
[Applause]
that's why you're the Hall of Fame
together all right Michael Irvin is here
let's take a break we'll check the X's
and O's of this game and what he thinks
is gonna happen and so people are giving
you grief they think you you've chosen
the Eagles rather have the Eagles win
one and then instead of the Patriots win
one more than us okay are they've been
going crazy about that and okay they
being New England Twitter patrons when
one more than us if they would have won
three or four years twice that just kind
of kicks us right off the curve I see so
you're rooting okay well this is crazy I
think I understand that you're rooting
for a rival to protect the Cowboys
Tipperary pay shouldn't override a
permanent thing they don't understand
your this year the serie I'm trying to
see this thing for the baby Dallas
Cowboy fans that are coming here and
they should have the right to both with
the most trophies Michael Irvin another
segment with him all right welcome back
here to our studio so again you were
referring to this and might as well
since we're on TV only here this is we
every year as a tradition a poster board
of our show logo for the Super Bowl
that's right and we have all the guests
sign it I mean here's a logo you know do
you notice I'm wearing skates in the
logo skates in the logo they put skates
on me Oh out here yeah but and and you
know since you know we're good friends
my my running style as you know this is
not particularly indicative I did have
them move this leg in three and a half
years ago alright so this is what you
signed here's Rodney Harrison with him
yeah yeah and then this is you
Super Bowl 21 Roman numeral he went in
Roman right right right right
in Indian I dropped that a little what
they call little sugar on top of that
thing right there called aho elf that
comes rich they all have to sign that
board
you know buddy's got the three with the
HOF that's so so Brad Bradshaw coming
and I was talking about my three rings
and he said all right if you're on hold
sting if you're on hold stay on hold
please because we're gonna take your
calls in our number three when Patrick
Peterson joins us to finish up our
number two Michael Irvin's still hanging
out here to my left
okay why do you now I know you said you
wanted the Eagles to win because it
would preserve the three out of the four
for the Cowboys being the only one to do
that well the teachers have done it once
right okay so you're saying you walk the
waist when I walked away as like okay
three in four years we're good that that
shouldn't happen again because it was
coming up on free agency and then the
patrons goals and doing oh my god they
tap that pretty quickly right and now
they have a chance to do it again I got
many reasons that I rather the Eagles
get this one all right so now give me
give me the scenario in which you are
proven correct as the seer and that the
Eagles pull this off well okay you can't
beat Tom Brady with one element you
can't beat him that's Miller with a
great defense and you can't beat Tom
Brady with just a great offense you need
both elements hitting on all cylinders
and and and the Eagles who I was worried
about going into the championship game
Nick Foles he hit that cylinder mark now
the thing I'm worried about is the
defensive plan plan is so great and I
know quietly the defense has talked
amongst themselves like you know a man
that's not Carson whiz here no man it's
Nick Foles they won't say this to Nick
they'll just talk we got to keep this
thing under 10 points we got to keep
this thing under 14 plus and they have
been doing that but now since when since
since Nick Foles put up all them points
I hope that doesn't diminish their need
to keep the New England Patriots down to
14 points because if they can keep him
down and of course they can play
anywhere like you played last week they
got a chance of winning this game I
think they do but I think they can don't
you think that's going on the Patriots
who they should be able to score on this
defense don't you think and for well
well that's see that's what we say now
that's what we said and we said it
earlier when we watch this defense this
defense was horrible
I remember Marshall whom I miss very
much I'm saying if Bill Belichick got
this defense into a Super Bowl it would
be his greatest coaching job ever his
greatest coaching job yet because when
we sold his defense at first
historically back it was historically
historically bad and and he and he did
exactly that he did exactly that
he got this defense into a super bully
at this team into a Super Bowl how it's
just a how did he fix the defense how I
think it's just again just based on what
everyone that we're hearing from from
Willie you heard from Rodney and our one
is it's just they have a system they
have a system in place the duty again
you hear do your job all the time right
and it was interesting in the national
championship game when Georgia was
beating Alabama and Nick Saban said I
guess going halftime what we just got to
go out and tell these kids you got to do
your job oh I heard there it is okay
it's so simple but yes they have a
system in place and if they call a
defense do not freelance and that's not
sure it took I'm sure it took right I'm
sure it took Gilmour some time to
realize that you don't freelance here
there's the kicker right there is it
when they say do your job it's not just
a physical thing it's actually a mental
thing don't just do your job shoulders
down do them shoulders up also be in the
right place and the defense will take
care of itself that's him saying stop
trusting all of your physical gifts
trust what we're putting together trust
us
system trust the places that we will
have you in because we know better than
you what they're about to call so we're
putting you where you need to be and in
making it giving you the best
opportunity to make plays and and he's
just incredible at it man just miss he
makes at halftime is incredible how
tough is it to buy into that as a player
when you just step in there you despite
the number of rings and trophies in the
case right Gilmore you so you got
players like that coming in saying yeah
I've gotten to this place doing things
my way
you know doing things my way yeah you've
gotten to this place where you got a big
contract you've been playing well but
now you're trying to get to a place
where you want to win championships your
way had produced that his way has so you
could buy into this and I think it's
easier to get guys to buy into it when
there's ways have produced Super Bowls
like he has Purdue it sounds like to use
the pop culture analogy from pulp
fiction that's just pride messing with
your mind you were gonna throw the fight
and if you think about it that's just
pride this is messing with your mind
that is a great that's a great quote -
that's a great quote that's what it is
and that's exactly what it is when you
get guys that come over and and try to
think oh I can do this that's just pride
it's just pride messing with your mind
and let pride be egon and get back on
the bill a chick train and then of
course having the the the wherewithal to
sign the players who do have the
physical abilities cuz Gilmore made the
play that prevented another Tyree
Manningham moment to prevent New England
from getting here he made that play to
knock that throw from portals to
Westbrook away to seal that game which
is a hell of a life lock and he said
that he was also recalling the technique
to use I guess in his way his offhand
his front hand mm-hmm the technique that
Patricia and Belichick have been
pounding into his head all year long as
opposed to that back in yeah it's what
he said the goal go out and go snatch it
but just not yeah it's good technique
because first of all if you don't get
caught you can kind of keep their Jersey
down right
[Laughter]
thanks for helping kick off the show
here this week and I look forward to
seeing you on some we're gonna spend an
absurd amount of time together we always
have a great time Richard when I did DP
show this morning I told DP the one time
one mistake I made I said you know I sit
next to rich every day a meteorologist
but you sit right next to each other and
I said I was I said I wore one of your
hats because I was trying to come
through the airport and hi and I warned
ahead I forgot and I walked into me and
rich was staring at me like you are not
sitting next to me with his head off
actually what I did in the 30 seconds I
waited to a moment where Earth was
talking about standing up for your
teammates during the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience